this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one app in finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash apps cash
card just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack chipotle
taco bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market now what's up my
babies yeah turn mine up to a little bit
just a little bit you guys it's episode
102 what the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] did we
keep doing this for a hundred and two
weeks but it's episode 102 of
congratulations and it's on dude now
what we got you know look life's about
change it really is and anyone who tells
your life's not about change those
people are [ __ ] you know what those
people are they're not human they're
rocks and even rocks change yeah I think
about this right over the time rocks
change things change but this podcast is
the personification of change because
the life the light first of all is
different if you're looking at the new
the new part the new vid the video the
new podcast room it's the lights
changing we changed it to make it better
because it wasn't good and what wasn't
knocked it wasn't not good but it's
better now and also you know I can't
remember what else but there was
something else that was changing and
anyway I was gonna I was going to lead
with that but totally [ __ ] it all up
so it's all good we are getting the new
I thought that the guy was gonna come
and install the [ __ ] for the sound the
other day but he didn't so he's coming
in now tomorrow I think or the next day
to do it
so the sounds gonna sound [ __ ]
pristine next next episode and st. Louis
I'm coming to st. Louis I'm coming in
Louisville and Indiana Indianapolis this
weekend some of the shows are sold out I
think there's some left on st. st. Louis
because I'm playing a big venue so go
get those tickets and meet up with the
cult [ __ ] and let's do this man I'm
live on my app here they get to they get
the [ __ ] [ __ ] first I got the tattoo
I got a tattoo I added to my tattoo dr.
woo he was so good man the detail on
this [ __ ] eagle I got the eagle under
the under the under the fire here on the
video podcast you might be able to see
it up here but the the eagle is tired
even though he's [ __ ] trucking
through life it doesn't look tired he's
like me after I drink my americano so
that's what's up so um and yeah man
so I was about the speaking of
Americanos I was at the coffee shop and
this guy came up to me and I just
[ __ ] knew it
sometimes you can tell when a guy's just
gonna [ __ ] come through in the most
backhanded way first of all here's
here's of and I mean this and I know
this makes like almost zero sense but oh
by the way I have a [ __ ] stain on my
shin in my in my on my pants and it's on
the video podcast and I was like I was
about to change it I was about to change
my pants before the video but I was like
you know what dude you [ __ ]
need to know what's up that's how it is
and I don't you know even though the
life is about change you got to see me
how I am so I didn't change my pants for
you guys and it looks like somebody
wiped their [ __ ] [ __ ] with my shin
so that's cool anyway or so anyway what
the [ __ ] was I trying to say
was I said oh yeah here's here's how you
know some people are going to be back
handed to you if you're in Hollywood and
people are coming up if they both there
were two guys came up to me they both
look the same you know for some reason
if they look like versions of each other
you know I don't know what it is cuz
it's like I didn't look like them but
they looked like each other and they
were like oh this guy doesn't look like
us so we're gonna have to [ __ ] take
him down a peg and he came up and he was
like hey man dude I gotta tell you dude
he was like hey Chris he's like you
probably don't remember me but I come up
to you sometimes I seen you before
and I said I was a big fan dude I'm just
I'm such a big fan I really am do it's
so funny you're drunk girls thing I was
like all cool thank
man I really appreciate that it was like
yeah dude I showed it to my girlfriend I
was like up here we go here we go hey I
don't need a story you giving me a
compliment I don't need a story dude if
you're gonna compliment me hey you know
what compliments don't start with once
upon a time dude
he came up to him he was like yeah so I
said you I showed you I showed you stuff
to my girlfriend this can't go this this
can't go better than it already went you
know what I'm talking about he already
came up and said he was a big fan he
loves my stuff singled out a bit cool
great thanks bye
my hands tied now four can't turn around
okay so I was like he said yeah I showed
it to my girlfriend and she was like
that's not funny and we got into a huge
argument I said oh cool man I love
hearing when people think I'm not funny
and he goes like this uh-huh
that literally that's what he did and I
stared at him I stared at him because he
made this and I stared right into him he
made it it's not my fault what the [ __ ]
that's what happens you feel it
otherwise I have to feel it judo baby
you take the [ __ ] momentum and you
[ __ ] swing it right back that's judo
baby that's conversational judo
ah yeah man don't [ __ ] with me man
you know life is martial arts but uh but
yeah so he did that and I [ __ ] and
and I'm I'm Irish but he was with me and
he was like oh it's [ __ ] crazy how
many people come up here this is it just
a little older but no leave no Lola and
I don't know what he said because he
[ __ ] can't understand [ __ ] change
your [ __ ] the way you talk dude
you're in America you know what I mean
nobody blow when I'm with him and he
says something to somebody I just I'm
like here comes a what dude
here comes or what I know they're gonna
say what you should know even more than
that because you're you and it happens
more therefore clean it up clean up the
way you're saying it hey dick chin so he
just goes when people say what and he
says Oh
and then I gotta be like oh he's talking
about your [ __ ] shoes or something
yeah okay cool and then they say is that
a fake accent always with them cuz
sounds hats it ridiculous it sounds so
hard to kill us anyway dude what's up
dude I got the I got the [ __ ] wouldn't
make a dent shirt on you can get at the
[ __ ] Chris D'Elia store dude you know
why cuz 2019 I haven't put this shirt on
but I need [ __ ] to know that
2019 is dent less dude you got a [ __ ]
bank account in 2019 guess what that
[ __ ] is pristine and then bliss dude you
got to go [ __ ] use your Apple pay and
it's [ __ ] and it wouldn't do it I
went to a [ __ ] coffee bean today I
[ __ ] bought some coffees and some
yogurts and [ __ ] and it didn't make a
[ __ ] dead dude no I know that's only
like you know 11 dollars but still dude
it feels good to go use Apple pay and
have it not make a [ __ ] dent walk
into the coffee bean with a pristine
with your bank account in pristine
condition and leave the coffee bean with
your bank account and less in pristine
condition dude do you know what I'm
talking about go ahead give me the
[ __ ] backhanded compliments my [ __ ]
is still dead dude but that's what's up
man you know I don't know man but what I
do know is what I do know is speaking of
Apple pay what I do know is hey what's
worse what's worse
what's worse having to clean up diarrhea
all over a kitchen floor or the Apple TV
remote what's worse
what's worse I'd rather clean up
diarrhea on my linoleum floor than have
to use the Apple TV remote
go [ __ ] yourself Apple TV are you trying
to make it cool we're not ready yet the
world isn't ready yet first of all why
do we want remote controls to be smaller
we lose them anyway you don't need the
remote control to be the size of one
fires deck
you don't need them to be that big dude
you don't need them to be that big
because it's a it's a remote control you
can just grab it it can be that big and
you press the buttons and I don't ever
need the remote controls to be I don't
ever need the remote controls to be
[ __ ] what do you call it touch the
touch dude that's the what is this
Minority Report go [ __ ] yourself
with this [ __ ] where you can just like
swipe it and appletv make physical
buttons do you know why because they're
for more in short sleeve shirts and the
Apple remote is next to me in my bed and
then I and then I lean over and my skin
touches it
I [ __ ] fast-forward the second
episode of you on Netflix and I'm trying
to watch this stalker deal with this
check it's [ __ ] man
I don't need the [ __ ] Apple TV remote
to be the size of one fires dick and I
don't need it to be touch okay it's like
the most sensitive every time I tell
it's the most sensitive [ __ ] it's like a
premature ejaculation remote is what it
is you touch it and everything and the
warmth of your skin dude I hate it so
much and then the volume you're always
like come on come on come on because the
volume is at a physical button dude it's
the worst man Apple you don't need to
see that's the thing they feel like they
need to keep changing because if they
don't keep changing then they're not
being quote-unquote innovative and then
people are like well where's the new
[ __ ] but it doesn't need you if it ain't
broke don't fix man a remote control is
not something you ever need to update
it's just [ __ ] put the buttons on it
and that's good and everyone agrees with
me there's no [ __ ] way somebody
thinks that that's cool the Apple remote
TV Apple TV remote it's so [ __ ]
there's two buttons and and they have a
mouse pad on it a hat I don't have a
mouse pad on your remote control dude
turn them round Apple
and it's so it's it's so sucker [ __ ] too
because like when there when you when
you take out the Apple TV lavaca low
look at this remote well cool dude it
fits in my anus fits of mine is won't
even hurt and then you start using it
you start rolling all over bed and [ __ ]
and this is a bet all of a sudden you're
watching [ __ ] the world's most
dangerous prisons how many the world's
most dangerous prisons TV show is there
either gonna be by the way how many how
many are there thirty no there's more
how many the world's most dangerous
prisons are there they have them world's
most dangerous Russian prisons they have
the world's most dangerous Serbian
prisons the rows most dangerous prisons
in [ __ ] Antarctica there's nobody
even there that just locked up a bunch
of penguins and Santa the most world's
the world's most dangerous [ __ ]
prisons on Pluto it's like oh my god I'm
in here for I'm in here for thirteen
sargans I am serving my 13s Oregon term
I am hoping to get parole how many do
they have to be and they're always like
they're always like I've watched the
Russian one and they're always like he's
like you know I don't like I don't like
I don't like the serial killers that are
playing it for the TV you know I'm
talking about like just be look if
you're a serial killer and you're and
you did it you did it you did it you
don't have to act any certain way the
second you start acting a certain way
you're not creepy bro stop it relax
serial killer you did it
you're the creepiest you know if the
axed act extra it's like wearing too
much makeup as a chick you already got
all this stuff that makes me go boy
yelling hey babe why do you need to
all that makeup on you already got all
the stuff that makes me go bracket quook
quook quook he already got me a squirt
boner now why are you putting ruby red
lipstick on when I already went
boi-yoi-yoing or Braca kakakaka oh
that's for you do this contour [ __ ] bro
what hey are you a canvas up contouring
say yeah put a little bit of foundation
on put a little bit of [ __ ] blush on
go to lunch that's it what do you need
to be foot putting that [ __ ] shiny
[ __ ] under your eye and then [ __ ]
shading it like this like you're a
[ __ ] Apache Indian and then just hey
you're painting your face if you do that
put on a kimono go do Kabuki theater say
yeah yeah I don't know I need to do that
to my abs though I need to do that to my
abs and just strut around but gained a
little weight first though do you know
I'm talking about gained a little weight
and then just start walking around with
[ __ ] killer
Shadid abs and girls are like oh and I
go it's like your face see ya girls go
ill I go like this it's like your face
[ __ ] and just listening to [ __ ] 80s
songs with a Walkman yeah you're trying
to make dudes go breka kack kack kack
put on less makeup that's all and that's
a [ __ ] you know what that is dude hey
you trying to make you trying to make
dudes go Braca quook quook quook put on
less makeup little and then
you're trying to make dudes go
boi-oi-oing stop stop making your face
look like an Apache in the end you're
trying to give dude squirty boners say
take off that kabuki makeup I'm Krista
Lee I approve this message I'm running
for mayor dude I want to buy I want to
buy airspace and do that for real not
even when it's time to vote for mayor's
just like after they did it three months
and then be like didn't they already
vote for mayors god damn dude there's
videos of men contouring their abs dude
guy work out and eat lettuce
what are you doing 302 [ __ ] everything
up that movie 300 [ __ ] everything up
guys remember when that movie came out
guys were just like did you see his
[ __ ] guys his body yeah man they
painted it head they CGI'd [ __ ] 40
ABS
right above his bathing suit line head
and then they painted it head they
painted it hat and then they [ __ ]
CGI'd it hat remember that [ __ ]
Persian guy in 300 and he was so like
flamboyant and so tall and then he
talked like this that was the creepy
issue let me if I saw that when I was 12
I would have had the biggest nightmares
of all time let's look it up let's look
it up the Persian guy in in 300 300
Persian it was the it was actually the
scariest thing here look at this look at
that look at the videos people make look
at the videos people make here we go
Thermopylae here we go
listen this guy's voice it's good the
[ __ ] out of me when I was a kid this
would scared [ __ ] up this would
yeah cuz he comes down all gay and [ __ ]
like he's got no how much does
what's-his-name look like a [ __ ]
what's his name this guy the bleed of it
the Gerard Butler that's his name
how much does he like just he looks like
such a guy that like just gets fat in
between shoots like we're all so he's
got the Russell Crowe effect going yes
there he is looks so gay the guy comes
down he's got lipstick on he's he's
contouring and [ __ ] by the way so many
people scariest guy in the whole world
let us reason together ninth up he
thought me a regrettable waste it would
be nothing short of madness were you
brave King and your valiant troops to
perish
all because of a simple misunderstanding
there's much our culture's good share
you noticed we've been sharing our
culture with you all morning
yours is a fascinating try you now we
were defiant this guy should have won
best our face of annihilation Best
Supporting Actor in the presence of a
god it isn't wise to stand against me
leonatus
an imagine what the horrible fate awaits
my enemies when I would gladly kill me
of my own man for victory and I would
die for any one of my you Greeks take
pride in your lost lanthum they had some
matrix lamb stock then I hear that one
and I would die but an ancient slam and
he knew it does the first lemma well in
history about us imagine what the
horrible fate awaits my enemies when I
would gladly kill of my old man for
victory and I would die for any one of
my ancient slam [ __ ] Leonidas slam
Leonidas dude I gotta have a son and
named him Leonidas how [ __ ] annoying
would that be in kindergarten Dave here
Richard here Zach here
Leonidas hi zurk sis you know I'm gonna
name my kids Erick sis who's the guy who
played the Persian guy what's his name
thermopile a that's him that's not him
it's thermopile a therm thermo-pile ii
from apple i Thermopylae monopoly
Thermopylae oh axis luksus imagine being
in class I'm anemic in Turkish and teach
them to talk like that
David yeah here Steven here Katie here
Zach here
Xerxes here just a [ __ ] baby with
jewels all over and a [ __ ] he's super
tan with no shirt on and just [ __ ]
cool neck like golden neck collar
and he's so [ __ ] privileged I don't
want to do my homework I have men that
will do it I don't want to do my
homework I'll have none God ordered a
baby so let's go play kickball man get
out o win this thing
Xerxes I mean you know a more confusing
name to spell the news XS x ER x yes so
you know what Dirk says sounds like a
[ __ ] a shop at the mall that that
like you're like how is this still in
goddamn business and it's next to Orange
Julius and Club Monaco and they sell
[ __ ] black clothes and tan clothes
and that's it and you're like how how
the [ __ ] is this still in business dude
and they have some clothes that are
black and tan and you're like nobody
would wear that but you see [ __ ] you
would literally see like only Persians
wearing it and then in and in like an
interview you'd see like Jon Favreau
wear it and you'd be like what he Shops
at xerxis and he'd be like when I was
directing Iron Man 2 and you'd be like
that's that why is he wearing that
[ __ ] [ __ ] from xerxis oh wow
absolutely why do you listen to this
podcast dude you know what are you guys
doing I make up a [ __ ] fairy tale
tralala [ __ ] and you guys hmm but it is
what it is I got my [ __ ] tattoo and
I'm good I'm happy it's an eagle I
already talked about it
I don't know listen what I got him my
[ __ ] dude you know what happened
actually let me do these [ __ ] ads and
then I'll get into this story I want to
tell you which is absolutely nothing but
it means so much to me dude blue apron
listen guys blue are you looking to
switch up your cooking routine I think
you should alright because a lot of
people just go they get the
dinner they get there quick [ __ ] they
get the the the fast food or cooking
takes forever or you gotta you know
figure it out yourself but this is
awesome alright you start this year off
fresh with the help from blue apron your
secret to easy meal planning choose from
a variety of plans including their kid
approved family plan vegetarian plan or
brand new WWE free style plan huh learn
how to poach saute and chop like a pro
all from the comfort of your own kitchen
blue apron really gives a better way to
cook man it's really awesome it's easy
and the food is all good i-i've been
doing it for over a year over a year and
a half it's still I have yet to have a
bad meal and they're not just okay
they're all great they really are and
you can you can tell them what kind of
stuff you like and then they send that
style of stuff it's just great chef
design recipes that use fresh seasonally
inspired ingredients meals worth sharing
on social media also because a very cool
and colorful and look nice and is in as
little as 20 minutes time-saving tips
and techniques videos helped me learn as
I go because I'm very visual I'm a
visual baby
so take the tour at a meal prep check
out this week's menu and get sixty
dollars off at blue apron dot-com /
Congrats that's blue apron comm /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
cryptos all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just the wealthy
alright so you don't need to feel left
out if your bank account has dents in it
non-intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence simple and
intuitive clear design with data
presented in an easy to digest way other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade but Robin Hood doesn't charge
Commission fees trade stocks and keep
all of your profits keep all of your
profits easy to understand charts and
market data place a trade in just four
taps on your smart phone I've done it
it's super easy trust me if I can do it
you can do it minute yet yeah but any
100 most popular sectors like
entertainment and social media and
curated categories like female CEOs they
got all this stuff and analyst ratings
of by hold cell for every stock learn by
doing just get into it get the app and
start doing it and you learned it by
doing it's like it's like jujitsu if you
do that
discover new stocks and track favorite
companies with personalized newsfeed and
custom notification is for price
movements so you never miss the right
moment to invest Juan uses him more than
I do and replaced his other stock apps
entirely that's one fire okay and this
is why one hire and keep him on it's
just the way that the app is designed
it's fun and it feels easier so Robin
Hood is giving listeners a free stock
like Apple Ford or Sprint to help build
your portfolio sign up at congrats dot
Robin Hood calm that's congrats dot
Robin Hood calm so yeah so here's what
here's here's something that this is
what I really wanted to talk about on
the podcast and this is very very stupid
and and very me and very important so
here's here's here's what I want to talk
about all right so I was at a restaurant
a diner actually that I like to go to I
like to go all the time me and the
fellas we go after after doing the show
and we have a good time and we go and we
laugh and by the way dude when I'm at
this diner or if I'm at a diner it
doesn't need to be this diner any diner
after I do shows and I'm with other
people that are friends other headliners
other openers other who ever it doesn't
matter even open my courage that I like
it doesn't matter we have a [ __ ]
silly goose time and that's it and it's
fun and we laugh and we cry laughing and
we make fun of each other because we're
guys and when you're guys you can roast
and when you're chicks you can roast too
but if you have too many chicks with you
eventually someone's gonna get their
feelings hurt because vagina and it's
all good but that's how it is usually
not trying to generalize but I am
okay if you got an Audi in your [ __ ]
downstairs area meaning a [ __ ] you
usually combust and occasionally
somebody's feelings get hurt but when
that happens you you know what I mean
you make fun of the guy even harder okay
because we're ruthless now I go to this
diner and I I'm with four of the guys
that I go to this diner a lot with okay
I got my opener Mike who's sitting there
probably thinking dumb [ __ ] like that's
crazy how birds can fly and we don't fly
you know and then I've got my Irish
buddy Marc who's probably thinking
although we're doing the little um deal
or
okay and I've got Craig sounds like this
and has the most French laugh of all
time because he goes hey okay and then
there's Joe and Joe is so from Chicago
it makes all the Bears on the football
team go like this wow that guy's the
most from Chicago okay
now also the thing about Joe is he looks
he couldn't look more like he's from
Chicago he also for some reason always
looks like he's wearing a backpack even
when he's not understand if I was
writing a novel about this guy in the
opening page there would be like and
there stood Joe Maurice he looked like
he had a backpack on even though he
never wore a backpack really unless he
was at an airport but even when he
wasn't at the airport he looked like he
was wearing a backpack something about
his shoulders and then I would start
describing like the [ __ ] fields and
the clouds or some [ __ ] because it's the
novel and all of us do that way too much
hey novels get it together
alright so one of the reasons why I go
to this diner is I like the food oh who
knew I loved the ambience I love the the
the the people there know me they know
my orders and [ __ ] I love the food okay
that's the main reason though food and
ambience is why I go if you're a waiter
or waitress you can
dicta me as long as the food in the
ambiance is good or if you're really
nice and the food is good the ambiance
can suffer a little bit you get there's
these three things that I like so this
restaurant has all of them all right now
Joe guy from Chicago who looks like he's
always wearing a goddamn backpack for
some reason like his mom was a a white
woman and his dad was a JanSport like
that's what--that's and so he came out
and he's like I'm a [ __ ] guy with it
levels anyway he you know he looks like
a turtle like he's got a shell like this
[ __ ] guy all right first I don't know
what he's got if he worked out he it
looks like he goes and works out his
lats a little too much all anyway that
I'm just painting a picture okay so we
get we get I get my I get a chicken
sandwich which is one of my hot shits
one of the hot shits i order all the
time I get the chicken sandwich or I get
the breakfast burrito or I get a
breakfast sandwich these are my hot
shits that I get I rarely stray from it
sometimes I get a [ __ ] vegan burrito
but these are the hot shits I get
chicken sandwich this is one of the hot
shits I get all right so I'm getting the
chicken sandwich and you know what I
like also the fries okay so they drop
the plate and I notice that the fries
are different all right
now I love the fries it's one of the
reasons why I go to this [ __ ] because
I love the food and part of the food of
the fries now everybody at the table we
all like the fries that's why we go
these fries are different okay Joe mr.
her [ __ ] phantom backpack we're from
Chicago says now let me also tell you
another thing about this guy he's one of
those guys that you know guys that are
always trying to rub it in your [ __ ]
face that like love food too much like I
don't give a [ __ ] how much you like food
oh you're a foodie I don't give a [ __ ]
oh you like putting food in your face oh
okay
let's talk about anything else oh you
like to oh yo yeah when you were in
Paris you had some good meals ah cool
hey do me a favor kiss my taint okay I
don't care
nice good good job oh you had a burger
cool you know so
guys always thought he's got a [ __ ]
thing on Instagram he you know it's it's
a tongue-in-cheek it's a funny thing but
he says it's called Joe eats and he does
a [ __ ] thing is like I mean a burger
from Shake Shack having had you know
having an Shake Shack yet heard a lot
about it gonna eat it and then he eats
it he's like no it's really good and
it's called Joe eats hey you know anyway
so so the they come down the fries are
different and Joe with his [ __ ]
always commenting on food [ __ ] he
says I got different fries they look
good okay blood-curdling anger now let
me tell now let me explain now let me
explain me here okay first of all he's
doing the thing that he always does
talking about food now step one I take I
take one step up to anger heaven do you
understand me I'm taking one step up to
anger heaven okay because he's doing the
thing he always does that is that you
just if you don't hate your friends you
ain't [ __ ] you understand what I'm
saying when your friends you know if
your friend like likes if your friend
like loves Blazers or some [ __ ] and then
you see them walk in with a new blazer
and you don't hate him for that a little
bit you ain't [ __ ] okay yeah I
understand he's your friend you love him
but you gotta be a guy's [ __ ] guy
with his Blazers always with his Blazers
you got a new [ __ ] tweed Blazers with
the patches on go [ __ ] yourself dude
you ain't [ __ ] if you don't think that
alright and you know okay so that's it
alright so now this guy's doing this
thing as fries look good now now one
step towards anger heaven okay and the
the the waitress goes like this oh yeah
they're just temporary we're gonna get
two old fries back soon in about a week
but we got these now he says oh they
look good second step to anger heaven
okay so actually third step that's the
second step when she says they're
temporary okay third step to anger
heaven okay so now let me tell you
second step she
says they're temporary so now she says
they're temporary because she thinks Oh
Joe thinks they look good so now she's
going to [ __ ] think that these she's
gonna think about these in a favorable
way now we like the fries already now
their new fries he hasn't tried him at
all he just said they look good now
she's got that positive [ __ ] she could
go back into the kitchen and be like hey
fries are ahead and she doesn't under
now so I say that to this - I said Joe
are you [ __ ] kidding me dude you just
said these fries look good now she's
gonna go back with that positive energy
and maybe what if she mentions it to the
[ __ ] cook and we liked let me add do
you like the fries do you like the
[ __ ] fries here all the time he says
uh yeah good yeah I just thought these
ones looked good I said beginning tribe
so now when she came back I said hey
these fries were temporary right and she
said yeah I said oh good because I love
the other fries and then she walked away
and I said I didn't want to do that I
didn't want to have to do that but I had
to [ __ ] do that because I had to
level out his idiocy with just blindly
saying the fries look good when you
didn't even [ __ ] who gives you [ __ ]
what food looks like so so I'm like I
had to [ __ ] save the day and be like
yeah I and he was like I'm just saying
it look I don't see the problem
and I said yeah okay well let me explain
something to you when you get the fries
here when you get the fries here do you
ever leave any of the fries on the plate
and he says well no and I said then what
the [ __ ] are you doing
you're a CUDA bro I looked at him right
in his face I said you're a CUDA I don't
even know if he knows what that means I
ain't know what it means cuz you know
he's my buddy but dude that's a CUDA
move to just see new fries bro to just
see new fries and get excited what are
you a baby what are you six dude if it
ain't broke don't fix okay it was like
end of [ __ ] and justice for all dude
I murdered him bro and he understood I'm
a good lawyer when it comes to being at
a diner I'm a good lawyer I represent
fries I'm a good lawyer
I represent dude fries neither do you
need a union representation fries I'm
here for you man
guys just blinds me I look good and
didn't even taste him and I [ __ ] gave
him one he goes are too hot yeah man
well looks like you [ __ ] up man
if I go back there and they have those
fries I'm gonna make Joe eat all of them
all of them all of them I'm gonna get a
[ __ ] whole side of him I'm a Mick mm
we'll watch him do it he's like God I
don't really carbs on the weekdays he's
one of those guys yeah he bread only on
the weekends oh really wheat bread on
the weekends yeah and then [ __ ]
Thursday I'll catch him slipping dude
I'll catch him slipping I'll see he
[ __ ] eats a little bit of a bun I see
dude you know what you got you know what
you got in your backpack bread that's
what you got dude phantom backpack um
anyway what is the [ __ ] thing Oh
we're at 40 minutes already wow I guess
I should do the second one here or
whatever dude you know what I by the
seat of the pants this is the podcast
dude
I'm enjoying myself man I am enjoying my
self Boogie Nights we you know dude I
have notes in my thing I wrote this I
don't I this has been on here for weeks
and I never remember what it means I
swear to God
it's called this is the note I wrote
gotta do a duty moon you do write it to
me how do you know what that is one far
as I go I know what it is is it a viral
thing what is it
really well I didn't remember seeing it
got a do a duty moon news duty he types
in Google News duty dude I'm fired just
types a news duty you Greeks take pride
in your logic your creeks take pride in
your logic I gotta teach my [ __ ] kid
to talk like that hello daddy I'd love
to have some cereal or would you like
Cheerios are for plebeians give me Froot
Loops I'd like to put them in my mouth
and digest them have them travel down my
esophagus store in my belly for three
and a half to four hours and then sit on
the toilet and rock at them out of my
[ __ ]
daddy I only like beige food what's up
with kids who only like I would like
Turkey and potatoes if you put something
green on my plate I'll smear it in your
face or deck the walls with it I'll eat
everything beige I'll put it in my mouth
and then it'll travel down my itself I
guess and then it'll store itself into
my belly for three and a half to four
hours and then I was sit on the toilet
in rocket base [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
why do you listen to this podcast you
know why am I like this
no dense though bro news duty you know
gotta call this episode news duty for
sure news duty do you ever think you
think waking up this morning you'd write
down news duty you ever do that I do
that all the time didn't think when I
woke up today I'd be saying news duty
alas news duty
did you see the r.kelly thing
did you see the our Kelly our Kelly
in Ethiopia
I mean first first of all first of all I
sent this to the group chat and he goes
like this and and and Mike my opener who
like thinks about birds a lot flying
probably because he's [ __ ] there is
he goes oh it's fake and it made me mad
because he's just a [ __ ] nicer and
it's not fake and if you know anything
about he's like looks doesn't look like
the lyrics are matching up with his
mouth and I'm but you got to understand
they were filming it in a [ __ ] arena
so they got the reverb in the [ __ ]
the time delay and all the [ __ ] and you
got to understand you got to know
r.kelly you got to be smarter than that
and know about what are Kelly would do
and this is right in line with what he
would do if you haven't heard this I'm
gonna play it for you
now our Kelly's a bad guy obviously he
pisses on fourteen-year-olds nothing
worse nothing worse okay but this guy if
he wasn't a bad guy and an actual good
guy this would be the most illest song
of all time because it's a basic and he
just says what he wants that's the thing
I like about R&B it's the thing I liked
about our Kelly songs too until I
realized he pissed on 12-year olds is
that it was so just like I'm in the
closet next to a parka and you'd be like
aw it doesn't mean anything that's just
what it is he's literally there so this
is what he sings to people in Ethiopia I
got it
say leadest okay first of all sings do
you haven't heard this oh wow Ivan get
rid of has not heard this oh oh dude
you're gonna love this bro have you
heard this oh yeah I showed it to you I
got it
do you have your passport is anything to
get your shots girl would you like to
come back just to send it home another
time said America the fact that he calls
himself Rob is really the icing on the
cake like he's like look call me Rob
down
[Music]
do you want to come back with I owe
Shakespeare
[Music]
are back with our
back with our went back to our wasn't
like got a little bit too familiar with
you it was like ah you know what I
shouldn't I told her my real name dude
dude did I'm sorry the greatest lyrics
of all time did you get your shots like
a badass [ __ ] sing an R&B but we
still gotta [ __ ] play cool by the
government yeah you still need your
passport even though I'm gonna do such
dirty things you still need your
passport did you get your shots and so
soulful and you got to see how many
people are at this [ __ ] so unn sexy
R&B is literally the sexiest [ __ ] I
mean dude it's the sexiest genre of
music of music I always said RMB is the
best the best music and the worst music
but dude I'm sorry
sexiest sexiest [ __ ] like this this
right here so sexy you know
so nineties this song peaches and cream
[Music]
this is sexy sis sexy want to put my
lips all over you peaches and cream and
then I mean son sexy think about a
[ __ ] girl in a doctor's office and
like it with like blinding [ __ ] neon
lights I want to make love to you but I
mean then there's this that song was
this [ __ ] huh
peaches and cream I mean did you get
your shots
I mean if 112 just broke off and was
like hold up though did you get your
shots you'd be like what the [ __ ]
peaches and cream dude I'm sorry but did
you get your passport made my jaw drop
and then when he said [ __ ] did you
get your shots I had to pick it up off
the floor like the mask
what is this YouTube this is it the
[ __ ] duty news okay dee dee okay I
mean the
he's giving me the [ __ ] alright this
is what I was talking about this that's
actually not what I I never saw that
that's not even what I was good
of course she [ __ ] this up big time
fired I'm surprised at the end of this
video you didn't hear somebody go you're
fired
first of all its Dierdre manga dot okay
this girl dude the most soil ding of a
name the most soiling the most name
selling the most disrespectful [ __ ] of
all time a fallen soldier and then calls
her [ __ ] doodoo go to hell mega
doodoo get up
Wow how about the fact that one fire
said YouTube this DD mega do do you know
Wow today's going all sorts of [ __ ]
ways huh did you get your shots would
you like to come back with Rob to
America least sexy name of all time
Rob dude it's so amazing how not sexy he
made it like he you could be like I want
to travel you on over the world and take
you in my private jet pack with me to
home and make sweet love to you but he
was just like do you have you just got
right down to it do you have your
passports
did you get your shots come back with
Roberts to America soon
sexy sometimes we trip and fall like
that that's the only thing most more not
sexy while we making love we trip and
fall and my Metamucil goes flying in the
kitchen and goes all over into my eyes
and mouth that's just as unsexy as did
you get your passport did you get all of
your shots to America um let's do these
[ __ ] things here I mean I got dude
what happened in Rob Kelly's [ __ ]
life that made him just be like I can
make a 50 minute song about being in the
closet I could that's the thing man you
surround yourself with guests people I
got to start doing that I got to
surround myself with only people who are
like that's a great idea
and then just start wearing all green
green leather pants green leather jacket
dude I'll tell you what man the more
famous you get the more you start got to
start dressing like a [ __ ] either of
someone from the future or someone who's
super Japanese but like that's what my
goal is dude to get so famous that I can
wear [ __ ] green leather pants a green
leather jacket and then a caller that
goes up like this that goes this high
and it's [ __ ] coned and a pendant
that is like this that goes along and
then it's like kind of like it keeps the
caller tucked in like this and then like
also tails dude that's how famous I want
to be and I'm going to walk around and
when people say like what the [ __ ] is
that guy wearing I want to go like this
is there a [ __ ] problem dude is there
a problem
and kill it dude I need to get my comedy
on that did you get your shots level
that's what I need to do just to make
R&B not sexy and still kill it dude that
is genius [ __ ] I need to make comedy not
funny but still make people laugh do it
I gotta get I think I'm there I'm there
some of my shits not funny and I go and
people laugh anyway I'm there dude oh
[ __ ] yeah did you get your shots
do do news um
yeah unbelievable I got it I got to
surround myself with yes men dude
forever
I did I'll just be like hey guys it's
dicks out Thursday let's go to a cafe
cool oh that's a good idea and we go and
it sticks out Thursday's and they get
arrested but I don't have a good lawyer
and I'm super famous alright here we go
quip the new year means new resolutions
and we've got one you're working on
twice everyday it's your oral health and
with a quip electric toothbrush sticking
to good habits is simple the guiding
features are like a built-in support
system for better brushing it's really
cool sensitive sonic vibrations for an
effective clean that's gentle on your
sensitive gums why people brush too hard
and some electric toothbrushes are too
abrasive the built-in two-minute timer
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides and to help you
clean your whole mouth and evenly when I
ever since I started brushing with quip
I've noticed that my gums don't hurt as
much because sometimes you go too hard
but with this you don't have to you let
them do the work multi-use cover works
at as a stand mounts to mirrors and
slides over your bristles to pack and
protect your clip I bring it on I bring
it all on the road I'm going to
Louisville soon i'ma bring it okay it
declares your sink or cabinet and it
makes traveling with an electric
electric toothbrush is way easier brush
heads are automatically delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just $5 a friendly reminder
when it's time to refresh and to stay
committed to your oral health
seventy-five percent of us use old
worn-out bristles that are ineffective
don't do that I love quip
at home on the road it makes my mouth
feel good that's why I love quip and why
over 1 million happy healthy mouths do
to quip starts at just $25 and if you go
to get quip calm Congrats / Congrats
that's get quip calm / Congrats right
now you can get your first refill pack
for free
that's your first refill pack at GE tqu
yp.com / congrats do you have your
passport cash app you already know the
cash app is the number one app in
finance but did you realize you can get
the most powerful debit card in the
world with the cash apps cash card the
cash card comes with boosts a feature
you can't get anywhere else because cash
app invented it better you select a
boost in your cash app swipe the cash
card and save 10% or more at Whole Foods
Shake Shack Chipotle Taco Bell
chick-fil-a and all coffee shops around
the country the coffee shop boost takes
$1 off at any coffee shop including
Dunkin and Starbucks drink hundred cups
a year that's save a hundred dollars
it's simple become a part of the
greatest rewards program ever and
download the cash app now it's the
number one app for a reason and the cash
card is the only debit card with boosts
so of course when you download the cash
app and enter the referral code congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund offense fund visit the App Store or
Google Play market and download the cash
app and every time you remember if
you're a baby every time you use the
cash app it doesn't make a bad it
doesn't make it Dan did you want to be
dent list get the cash app did you get
your passport did you get your shots do
you want to come with Rob to America
what's a least sexy name Coral do you
want to come with Carl to America
see these weren't all white on that [ __ ]
I gotta get going with this [ __ ] by the
way people I saw people have my show
that were dressed in all white because I
just mentioned that once in the podcast
and then when I saw them I realized
woops Cana seems like the KKK so we're
scrapping that idea
so let's change the color blue if you're
a real baby you come with all blue you
come with blue jeans you come with blue
shirts you come with a blue hat you
[ __ ] rock blue that's the color for
us babies because we are not racist we
do not want to wear all white kind of a
weird time to wear all white and and we
all be doing that because of the KKK and
stuff anyway we chillin man I'm going
I'm I'm excited for the follow the
leader tour and we're cuz you know what
I mean in the moment right now where I'm
happy that I am on the road I'm happy
with my material
I'm keeping it going and thanks for
everybody for also coming watching
Netflix the comedians the world a lot of
really good feedback on that is very
cool and globally I'm getting hit up
with a lot of people a lot of people
like in [ __ ] you know different
countries because they see it so that's
really cool so maybe daddy will get out
the [ __ ] Sweden and just do some you
know comedy out for the for the Swedes
or something like that would be very
cool so but Louisville Indianapolis and
Louis first Boulder Colorado Colorado
Springs them first let's just some
misconnections huh let's do some of
these I feel like are Kelly would jump
on these misconnections
ah here we go
Daniel in Belmont Shore from Steve in
Boise parentheses bill measure Oh
Danielle its Danielle and Belen sure
Danielle if you somehow see this please
reply so I can get in contact such a
Hail Mary good such a Hail Mary hey dude
you know this is the sat out of all the
[ __ ] posts this one is the SS saddest
one Daniel in Belmont that that's an art
Kelly lyric Daniel then yelling man
mount do you remember me from Belmont
Shore from Boise if you somehow see this
reply so I can get in contact I'm
bringing you bet to Boise all right next
one oh I love ones that start with this
word horny from work my Latin [ __ ] ass
is ready to get [ __ ] hard all right well
cool man horny from work my Latin [ __ ]
ass is ready to get [ __ ] hard now I
think a [ __ ] ass is gay slang for
butthole
cuz no chick would write this horny for
my Latin [ __ ] ass here's the body and
he straight got bad music comma there
any straight comma guy that just needs a
to drop a load this is our Kelly I am a
wearing I am a wearing sexy panties for
a hung papi I am gay crossdresser who
loves where women clothes for my papi
came in really really doubling down on
this puppy thing huh
soy un puto gay cue me gusta I that
produce soy un puto gay cue me gusta
vesti roomie de mujer para me Pepito
do not contact me with some unsolicited
that's [ __ ] are Kelly's note to the
[ __ ] Persian guy in 300 horny from
work my lettin [ __ ] ass is ready to get
[ __ ] Oh heard
oh wow wow look at this one sitting
period my behind your fit what's up with
this [ __ ] why can nobody nobody who
goes on Crescent Craigslist has a grasp
of the English language
sitting period my behind your face and
then in parentheses Hollywood hey man
you don't need parentheses here you
already [ __ ] bastardized this whole
language you wanted me to sit on your
face with my behind
so proper you wanted me in leggings or
whatever Oh or whatever I was
comfortable I like it that way better
you wanted me in leggings or whatever
you like you wanted me in leggings or
whatever I was comfortable as long as I
sat on you you offered a reward god I
love how these guys are like vague but
also specific sitting my behind your
face so specific but also vague cuz what
the [ __ ] that mean and then you wanted
me to sit on your face with my behind so
I get that you wanted me in leggings or
whatever I was comfortable as long as I
sat on you you offered a reward what's
the reward money what's the reward taint
on your [ __ ] face going back with you
to America offering to pay for shots
alright man looking for a top chubby
chaser we're all the fit top chubby
chasers at Latino chub 28 looking for a
chaser around my area this guy's acting
like it's the government like it's a
[ __ ] like it's like some some this is
like how like if you were gay and a
China and and liked fat guys and and and
it was like a CIA operation this is how
you'd talk about it
Latino chub 28 looking for a chaser
around my area if you wanted chill send
a pic and stats be around my age under
35 I'm a top chub each looking for a top
chubby chaser is our top chubby chaser
an area where all the fit top chubby
chaser is that put out Latino chub 28
looking for a chaser
we need a chaser as we looked for a
chaser it would be like a documentary
series on Netflix would you look for a
chaser as he was looking for a chaser he
noticed he noticed there were no fit top
chubby chasers so he asked we're all the
fit top chubby chasers up we're the fit
top chubby chasers that do not contact
me with unsolicited services or offers
got a chubby chaser in the area all
right oh wow this one dude right here
the title is black snake Wow
so not cryptic this guy thought he was
so clever well I'm gonna read this to
you this guy thought he was so clever
and so not cryptic first of all black
snake so you know where this is going
okay not there's a black [ __ ] innuendo
in there all right yeah black I'm this
is the [ __ ] thing I'm not afraid of
big black snakes certified certified
snake certified snake charmer here late
forties white guy hey we know only a
late 40s white guy would say that
respond for details details
uh you were pretty detailed right there
black snake
hey just so you know I'm not afraid of
big black
makes you take your big black snake out
I'll charm it right I'll charm it right
in my [ __ ] mouth you know why I'm
certified hey where do you go to get
certified for black [ __ ] Robin did you
but-first though did you get your shots
cuz I'm certified do you have your
passport did you get your shots I'm not
afraid of black snakes wow dude
wow wow dude that's amazing that
somebody wrote that props to this guy
why isn't there ever anyone that's just
like black [ __ ] hey I want to suck a
black [ __ ] that's it do not contact me
with unsolicited services wow that was
amazing
alright well I guess we're all good
fellas so I guess that's it make sure we
do Twitter so we just [ __ ] skip it
when I'm [ __ ] you know out the door
every time I think we got to do a
[ __ ] most [ __ ] up Instagram post
the least next time and we also gotta
give you know we're gonna do we're gonna
do an elder next time that's what we're
gonna do we owe some elders there's been
some [ __ ] two cool babies out there
so follow the leader Target ticket to
Chris D'Elia calm Louisville st. Louis
Indianapolis Boulder Colorado Springs
Salt Lake City Vitus in Milwaukee
Chicago Seattle Hamilton Ontario Windsor
on teller account Kalamazoo Michigan
some of these are sold out but go check
it out some of them aren't but make sure
if you're not if you're coming to the
show that you get your shots already and
you have your passport download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market and two rewards code
Congrats get $5 and give five dollars -
times up download the Chris D'Elia app
also follow the store twitter at Chris
D'Elia store we see those babies hoodies
out there those are looking awesome and
I love the
subscribe to the YouTube channel and
rate and review the show it really helps
our [ __ ] and non-stop my episode of
comedians of the world is on T is on
Netflix so check that out as episode 2
you can check it out by the way if
you're not in America
it just shows your country first there's
a drop-down menu just click it and then
go to the US comedians and I'm the
second one so look at it there and
thanks a lot in videos that video
episodes go up every Tuesday or
Wednesday but you guys are the best
thanks a lot babies bye bye
[Music]